[Musik]
9 uhr 30 fliegerhorst aigen im ennstal
die heimat von 12 erneut drei helikopter
des österreichischen bundesheers die
beim schneechaos anfang 2009 10 einen
wesentlichen beitrag zur hilfe und
rettung eingeschneiter personen
geleistet haben
für die meisten von uns ist im
katastrophenfall der einsatz des
bundesheers selbstverständlich nicht so
für manuel lutz mann der heute auf
einladung den steirischen fliegerhorst
besucht persönlich fällt das nicht
einmal welche seiten regierung
unterstützung oder fähig zum tragen ist
auf der werbung oder aber der
bergrettung also wo der pc schon am
objekt sar steht für search and rescue
also suchen und retten und als dank für
den sar einsatz hat manoel kurzerhand
eine schnee botschaft geschrieben und
diese dankesbotschaft wurde von einer
alu at besatzung entdeckt mit ins rollen
gekommen ist die heutige einladung in
dem fliegerhorst aigen gemeint der
kommandant der zwölf alle drei
oberstleutnant udo koller kommt
persönlich um manuel zu begrüßen als
dankeschön für sein dankeschön ist
geplant dass manuel heute während eines
ausbildungs fluges mit im helikopter
dabei sein darf
[Musik]
russland ist der nebelsuppe auf ihren
flug überhaupt zu denken wenn man unsere
meta logen sind sehr zuversichtlich dass
der nebel auflöst und dass wir in
absehbarer zeit wahrscheinlich in ein
bis zwei stunden spätestens abheben
können
zum flugdienst und während manuel eine
ausführliche führung durch den
fliegerhorst genießt sollen meteorologen
recht behalten der nebel verzieht sich
und bei manor kommen erinnerungen an
einen einsatz vor 13 jahren auf als
bergretter fliegt der damals mit einer
alu at allerdings hängt der außen an der
winde und sitzt nicht im helikopter
drinnen recht interessant es ist immer
massiv den pfleger jahrzehntelang
eigentlich nie waren oder etwas haus
darüber fliegen aber darf man mal zum
mitfliegen
es wäre das erste mal drin sitzen und
für manuels premierenflug könnte das
wetter nicht besser sein
der himmel ist mittlerweile wolkenlos
kurz vor dem start werden noch
erinnerungsfotos gemacht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die startfreigabe wird vom tower erteilt
was folgt ist ein fast 90 minütiger flug
mit fernsicht ohne ende so weit das
sehvermögen leben reicht
ziel des ausbildungs fluges von pilot
protokoller ist natürlich nicht nur das
genießen der atemberaubenden fernsicht
das trainieren von hochgebirgs landungen
sorgt ein manuell für einen erhöhten
adrenalinpegel
am schluss des ausbildungs flugs werden
wir zeugen eines beeindruckenden flug
manövers dialog wird von hoher
geschwindigkeit abrupt gestoppt um dann
eine punktlandung am fliegerhorst
vorzunehmen
ein manöver das protokoll mit äußerster
präzision durch wird
die maschine ist erleichtert dass sie
hier ist sie agiler und auch einfacher
zu fliegen und das hat man bei uns ganz
besonders gespürt nachdem wir wenige
passagiere mit hatten und auch wenig
sprit deswegen hat das auch so
ausgesucht sein einfluss geschwindigkeit
quasi
ganz gewaltig erziehungsberechtigten und
cola und man offizieller stellvertreter
rosa beton für den natürlich gewaltigen
flut erlebt man nicht alle tage
kann nur sagen es ist gratis wird da
ganz gewaltig das panorama die fernsicht
optimal